clean code functions part to clean code
is readable reusable and recyclable
software and JavaScript this is part 2
of how to write clean functions in
JavaScript special thanks to Ryan
Vermont for a lot of the code in this
video check the description for his
original article on the topic you should
always avoid side effects a function
produces a side effect if it does
anything other than take a value in and
return another value side effects could
be many things including writing to a
file or modifying some global variable
here's an example so we have let name
equals Bo Carnes function split name
into first and last name name equals
name dot split if we run the function
and if we console dot log the name we're
gonna see the split name up here but
look it's changing the the global
variable name to split up so now we
cannot access the initial variable
anymore so a better way to do it would
be like this and now if we run that you
can see it's consoling that log bo
Carnes and then it's consoling log this
split bo Carnes here because we still
have the original name and now we have
the new name because this function did
not change the global variable it just
gave back one one value okay the next
thing is that you don't want to write
two global functions polluting Global's
is a bad practice in JavaScript because
you could clash with another library so
an example of this is if you're trying
to extend one of Java scripts native or
array methods so for instance it's not
really good to add to this global
function or raise the glow function so
we don't want to just add diff to the
array prototype a better way would to
just use classes and extend the array
global so I'm gonna make this into a
class
there we go we just extended the array
global next thing is that you should
savor functional programming over a
period of programming now javascript is
not a completely functional programming
languages like some languages but
functional languages are cleaner and
easier to test so let me give you an
example of just how you can change
something from imperative to functional
so this is an imperative programming
section so we have this constant where
we are gonna have the the name and the
lines of code for each of freaks person
and then we have let total output equals
zero and then we'll have a for loop here
for let a equals zero I is less than
programmer output that length I plus
plus twelve output plus equals program
or output index I that line of code so
it's it's adding up all the the outputs
of lines of code so a way we can change
this so it's more functional is we're
not going to have a for loop here we're
gonna we're gonna change this to an
initial value and we're going to take
out this for loop
okay instead of the for-loop we have
just this one line control app equals
programmer output we are gonna map this
to the lines of code and then we're
gonna reduce all those lines of code by
putting them all together the F plus
lines of code we're gonna start at zero
so using math and reduce helps make your
code more functional next thing is
encapsulate conditionals so here's the
bad way to do it we're we're just gonna
have this it's going to say if and
they're gonna make conditional here so a
better way to do this would be to take
this out and I'm going to make this into
a function called good so now the
conditional is is a function so that
makes it easier to read next up avoid
negative conditionals here's the bad way
to do it we're C is domnode not present
note and then we're gonna say is not
this means not is no not present so it
makes more sense just to take out the
not and then you don't have a negative
conditional the next one sounds pretty
crazy at first but it's just avoid
conditionals altogether the way you can
do things without an if statement or
conditional is to use polymorphism to
achieve the same thing and the reason
why you'd want to do that is because
functions should really only do one
thing so if you have an if statement
then you're doing a lot of things with
your function so for instance if I had
this class airplane get cruising
altitude we're gonna have a switch
conditional so if the type is 777 we're
gonna return this but if it's Air Force
one we're gonna return this but if it's
the Cessna we're gonna return this
however there is a way we could do that
with polymorphism so I'm just going to
leave the old way of doing it and put
this
New Age right below it so we're gonna
have the class airplane but that we're
going to extend it class one seven seven
since airplane class Air Force one
extends airplane class Cessna extends
airplane and then we have a different
get cruising altitude function for each
each class of airplane so instead of
using the switch statement we can use
polymorphism and then we don't have to
have the switch statement so that's just
an example of how you can avoid
conditionals to make your code more
readable and then the last time I talked
about is to remove dead code this is
pretty straightforward if there's code
that you're not using anymore just
remove it so just in this example we're
only using this new request module we're
not using the old request module so we
can just take it out you're always going
to have um you're always gonna have it
in your version of history if you still
need it so there's no reason just to
leave it in there just in case thanks
for watching my name is beau Carnes
don't forget to subscribe and remember
use your code for good